me han pedido que haga la prueba de la
derivada de la raíz cuadrada de x he
pensado en hacer un vídeo de cómo se
halla dicha fórmula de la derivada de la
raíz cuadrada de x conocemos la
definición de una derivada es decir la
derivada de la función raíz cuadrada de
x es igual a y bueno vamos a cambiar los
colores para hacer esto más variado es
igual al límite mientras belta x se
aproxima a cero algunas personas les
gusta utilizar más h tiende a cero en
fin esto esto es irrelevante y yo
prefiero usar más delta x
entonces es la raíz cuadrada de x +
delta x menos menos la raíz cuadrada de
x entre delta x todo lo anterior entre
delta x
ahora mismo cuando miro esto no veo
demasiada posibilidad de resolverlo así
que lo que vamos a hacer es multiplicar
esta fracción por el conjugado de el
numerador es decir vamos a multiplicar
todo esto bueno déjenme escribirlo el
límite cuando delta x tiende a cero solo
estoy copiando lo que teníamos arriba de
la raíz cuadrada de x más delta x menos
la raíz de x entre delta x y voy a
multiplicar déjenme utilizar otro color
por la raíz cuadrada de x + delta x más
la raíz cuadrada de x entre la raíz
cuadrada de x más delta x más la raíz
cuadrada de x esto es un número 1 así
que por supuesto puede multiplicar lo
estamos pensando que x y delta x son
distintos de 0 entonces este es un
número bien definido de hecho es 1 y
recordemos que multiplicar por 1 es como
haber hecho nada realmente
así que escribimos límite cuando delta x
tiende a cero y esta parte es de la
forma menos b por b
déjenme escribirlo por acá abajo además
ve por a menos b es igual a a cuadrada
menos b cuadrada una diferencia de
cuadrados así que vamos a utilizar esto
en la expresión de acá arriba esto será
igual al cuadrado de esta primera
expresión que va a tomar el papel de la
a esto simplemente es el cuadrado de la
raíz cuadrada de x + delta x que es x +
delta x menos el cuadrado de esta
segunda expresión que simplemente
siguiendo la analogía va a ser el
cuadrado de la raíz cuadrada de x que es
x y todo esto sobre delta x por la raíz
de x + delta x
la raíz d
ahora vamos a ver como simplificando
tenemos una equis y un equis así que
esto se cancela y quedamos sólo con el
numerador y el denominador tenemos delta
equis acá y delta equis acá abajo así
que dividimos entre este número y nos
queda 1 de este lado y 1 de este otro
lado así que esto nos queda el límite
cuando delta x tiende a 0 espero tenga
espacio para ponerlo de 1 sobre y bueno
esto solo lo podemos hacer si pensamos
que delta x es distinto de 0 sólo se
aproxima a 0 pero es distinto entonces
decíamos la raíz de x + delta x más la
raíz de x ahora podemos tomar
directamente el límite cuando delta x
tiende a cero esto simplemente es
sustituir así que esto es igual a 1
sobre la raíz cuadrada de x más delta x
que se aproxima a cero y eso simplemente
sustituir
la raíz cuadrada de x
y esto es igual a 1 sobre 2 veces
la raíz cuadrada de equis y eso también
es igual a un medio de x a la menos un
medio
acabamos de probar que la derivada de x
a la potencia un medio es un medio de x
elevado a la menos un medio y esto es
consistente con nuestra fórmula general
de la derivada de x elevada a una
potencia digamos la derivada de a alá no
disculpen no está sino la derivada de x
a la n va a ser n x a la n 1
incluso cuando n es un medio que es el
de este caso espero que haya sido
satisfactorio no lo probé para todas las
fracciones pero es un buen inicio es una
muy común y espero no haya sido difícil
de probar
nos vemos en próximos vídeos